the end of China's zero covet policy has
become the start of an explosion in
coronavirus cases and under vaccinated
population with low natural immunity and
a loosening of restrictions has led to
scenes in China the rest of the world
has long put behind it scenes like these
overcrowded hospitals with patients
seeking help Pharmacy is running out of
cold and flu medication
and long queues at crematoriums there's
estimates up to 2 million people could
die in China due to the sudden loosening
of covet curbs
and correspondent Fabian kretchman joins
me now from Beijing with an update
Fabian what is it like in Beijing
currently
yeah actually within China Beijing seems
to be ahead of the curve ahead of the
developments that means um here the
first big uh covet wave of Omicron seems
to be peaking already we can see public
Life coming back into the city day by
day um the traffic is picking up uh the
morning Subways are filling up again
even some restaurants and bars are
opening up again but don't get me wrong
that doesn't mean that we are here at
the normal State no um it's still very
difficult to um for example order fever
medicine or even get self-tests to test
at home that's very difficult and if you
just look at the funeral homes and also
the crematoria basically there are long
queues in front of them and you can see
that it's really a big stress test but
the number of people who are recovering
is also growing day by day that means we
are slowly getting back to normal amidst
all of this for everyone does the
government even have an accurate picture
of the scale of the crisis facing the
country
well the fact that we don't have
reliable government information anymore
about covert deaths is a deliberate
Choice let me emphasize that because
just when um the first wave exploded
here in China the government decided to
change the criteria of what constitutes
a covert death it made them much more
stricter so basically now we have just a
very very little amount of covert deaths
which is really not credible and of
course if you want to see what's
happening here and I think the
government is of course willing to see
it then it's easy you just need to talk
to um doctors who work in Fever clinics
you need to look at the funeral homes
who are working 24 7 and um that's
really quite obvious so yes you can have
an accurate picture if you want to see
it Fabian very briefly will things get
worse before they get better
yeah most likely here Public Health
experts are predicting three winter
waves so the first one we're seeing
right now in the big cities the second
one will happen in mid-January during
the Lunar New Year travel season and
then until mid-march there will be a
third uh Wave by people coming back to
the city and bringing the virus back
into the offices so it will be a harsh
and long pandemic winter if we leave it
there thanks so much for joining us
today Fabian Christmas from Beijing
concern is also reflected in the online
conversations people are having in China
DW news Asia reporter hang shwen Lee has
been monitoring all of that for us
here's her update
he has hyper rush something we're
starting to see across the Chinese
internet again are sheep emojis it's
because the word sheep Yang has the same
pronunciation as positive in Mandarin
people have been using this to actually
joke about covert positive people at the
start of the pandemic and now many users
are actually using this Emoji to tease
themselves I guess maybe that's a way to
keep a sense of humor during really
really tough times now A lot of Internet
users say they've seen people uh
queering up and standing in long lines
to hoard test kids and painkillers such
as ibuprofen and with medicines now
extremely difficult to buy some are even
turning to Yellow canned peaches because
it's rumored to be effective in fighting
against infections and others seem to be
struggling to get treated a video has
been circulating online showing a nurse
and a father kneeling to each other the
father is begging his child to be
treated quickly but the nurse can't do
anything about it now this video can't
be verified for now but it has attracted
lots of reactions and comments some
people have criticized those who wanted
China to end the zero covet policy and
say that people are now equally unhappy
just as before and others blamed to the
Chinese government for opening up too
quickly without having enough
preparation
that was from DW news Asia reporter
Huntsman Lee joining me now for some
epidemiological context is Eric
feigleding he's an epidemiologist and
co-founder of the World Health Network
he joins me now from Washington DC Eric
an explosion in cases in China how
worried should the rest of the world be
yeah the explosion in cases I think
should worry the entire world because
the this surge is not going to be a
small temporary surge this surge is
going to likely be one of the largest
searches we have ever seen
um but uh China which has virgin fields
of many uninfected people and under
vaccinated people will suffer the
largest consequence but indirectly uh
the rest of the world will as well we're
talking about you know 60 of China are
more infected over the next three months
you know 60 of China is a very large
number and
um in terms of deaths we're easily might
see one million if not two million
deaths if China doesn't do anything in
terms of changing the course and
trajectory and in terms of you know
shortages there's already shortages of
uh pain medicine right uh in China and
as we know we're we are also suffering
shortages of children's pain medication
or feeding for medication in the U.S in
Canada and Europe as well so in terms of
Supply chains this could also disrupt
the global Supply chains of many
medicines and many consumer products so
I think the Ripple effects are going to
be large and as the chief
epidemiologists of China has just
recently said right the worst is yet to
come this is going to be potentially
three waves back to back
um as this initial wave and then the
lunar holiday wave at the end of January
uh Eric will Cascade it will Cascade for
quite a while and we will be in a world
of hurt for the next few months speaking
about this world of hurt are you looking
at potentially uh deadly mutations
emerging the reason I ask is because
China has itself played down the
possibility of deadly and highly
infectious mutations emerging from these
waves should we take those a show
assurances at face value
well I think we should take China's
actions that face value and one thing
China has actually said is that they
will ramp up uh surveillance testing for
variants The genome sequencing for
variants and across all Chinese cities I
think you should always look at what
they're actually doing instead of just
what they're saying but there's a lot of
mixed messages you know China's playing
down a lot of uh the the explosion of
cases they're saying oh we have few
deaths they're not reporting many deaths
but you don't need to have death reports
to see the overload of crematoriums
right um their absence is at work from
people who are sick
um there's entire media crews in which
they couldn't actually
um host an interview because most of
their team is sick
um like these these things are not just
random observations and then you know
famous operas singers in Beijing dying
at the age of 40. and whatever you see
those kind of things happening you know
that there's a lot of deaths and when
you see trying to wrap ramping up
surveillance testing there's going to be
uh no we know that there's going to be a
lot of variance that emerges when 800
million people get infected within three
months you talk about judging China
through China's actions do you see any
plan here for how Beijing intends to
tackle these latest outbreaks
yeah this is that's the policy and
political side that's hard to say
because they've resisted for a long time
um releasing mitigations and now that
they finally released it
uh if they reverse course also shows
that they're making they're admitting a
mistake but at the same time not
reversing Force they know what's coming
like China knows even if they don't say
like just by the sheer concern uh
they're doing we're ramping up uh stock
trying to also
um you know have more hospital beds and
building more fever clinics and also the
cheap epidemiologist words that the
worst is yet to come they know what's
coming but the issue is uh will they
have the you know the the humbleness to
admits that they need to reverse course
now the reopening wasn't like a western
reopen it wasn't like a Swedish approach
reopening you know it's like halfway
between the old Chinese
um zero uh versus the Western but I want
to emphasize that zero covet is not
equal to lockdowns you can't have zero
code in South Korea and Japan where you
don't have lockdowns but you have you
know premium masks for everyone contact
tracing
ventilation air disinfection standards
and plus uh usage of boosters and uh and
and better vaccines but you know whether
or not China will admit that they need
to either roll out by Vanilla vaccines
which they have not yet done or import
vaccines all of those things will be
very telling in the in those weeks to
come for for any success at getting
these outbreaks under control is it
imperative that China essentially import
Western vaccines because the record so
far on chinese-made vaccines has been
very patchy
well I think the issue is China's China
has many vaccines the the primary
vaccines are coronavac made by cynovac
inside of far those vaccines if you line
up and turn scientifically for their
neutralization uh capabilities are
ranked at the bottom of the list in
terms of their the weakest vaccines of
all and they have not updated them from
the original wuhan's by protein version
to the
um you know the Omicron or b85
subvariant that you know Pfizer moderna
has
in terms of the bivalent version they
haven't updated but China does have
other vaccines such as the inhaled
mucosal vaccines it's a it's a nebulized
aerosolized vaccine that you inhale
instead of getting an injection that one
they're just starting to roll out
um it's very promising because mucosal
vaccines have the ability to uh increase
or your protection gets infection and
the key here is prevention against
infection and transmission because that
will ultimately save more lives we leave
it there for the time but thanks so much
for joining us today Eric cycle thing
stay safe